the idea that even though you live you
know a high up in the sky you actually
have a feeling of being very close to
the ground and you're surrounded by
nature greenery
[Music]
what we hope to do in the temple zone
was to actually recreate that kind of
village feeling to think of the many
ways that we can actually encourage
community interaction it's almost as if
there's so many possibilities for the
meeting of fell residents that makes it
possible for them to interact so we
therefore created multiplied the effect
of human interaction in this dimension
vertically but horizontally when we
connected the bridges across all the
three blocks this other create the
interaction between residents in this
block and this book in this other block
the whole spatial program then becomes
something that is meaningful to the
entire community intimacy the study of
social science and neuroscience is that
people are happier in an environment
where they can make multiple positive
transient connection so we create those
spaces that were public but they also
for personal and in
in private at the same time in a
environment like the taboo so you know
if we can create more instances when
people cannot bump into each other
mix and I compare exchanges smell the
more we have of that the higher
possibility of people you know having
positive and happy encounters
[Music]
you